donald trump we have now learned
thanks to bob woodward's book rage
supposedly bragged about a secret
nuclear weapon system when he was
speaking to bob woodward during these
interviews that took place over the last
six months
for bob woodward's book this is
according to excerpts from the book that
have been released
uh trump talked openly about a weapon
system
with bob woodward that is supposed to be
secret and this was in the context of
telling bob woodward how close we
supposedly were to war with north korea
nuclear war in 2017
which is a whole horrifying nightmare in
and of itself and according to the
excerpts that the washington post has
published
trump told bob woodward quote i have
built a nuclear
a weapon system that nobody's ever had
in this country before
we have stuff that you haven't even seen
or heard about
we have stuff that putin and she have
never heard about before
saying there's nobody what we have is
incredible
and then in the book bob woodward goes
on
to say unnamed sources that he spoke to
and said what
what is trump talking about here sources
did confirm the existence
of a new weapon system to bob woodward
but they said they couldn't share any
details and they expressed
surprise that donald trump actually
mentioned it to bob woodward because
he wasn't supposed to the hill then
reached out to the pentagon for comment
the pentagon said they don't talk about
books that have not yet been published
and um when the hill did more
investigation into this
they spoke to for example james acton
from the carnegie endowment
for international peace and uh
what james acton said is this probably
is a submarine-launched low-yield
nuclear warhead its existence is
now known but the details remain
classified
this is so so there's two sides to this
one is we shouldn't even have this stuff
we need
nuclear disarmament and maybe trump
spilling the beans will help build that
case
the other side is donald trump is just
so irresponsible with classified and
secret information
and he criticized hillary clinton for
that and he criticizes adam schiff and
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi for that
and yet it's trump who has the record
of bragging about new weapons that are
publicly uh
uh unknown or semi-known and disclosing
details remember the thing about the
supersonic missile that
super duper missile that goes 17 times
the speed of sound or whatever
remember donald trump in the oval office
spilling
secrets from an ally to russian
spy recruiter sergey kislyak on and on
and on
but on the tail end of this it's not
new that donald trump is irresponsible
with information and much of it is
because of his narcissism which i will
get to
consider that donald trump's kids have
access to a lot of this information
who has jared kushner told about this
stuff
what has ivanka done or don jr with
knowledge
of these things uh and this is the
classic
attention seeking behavior of a
narcissist i've known many
serial liars in my life they're very
toxic very very toxic
sometimes they straight up for attention
say things that are lies
i knew someone i remember who said my
glasses are 500
no they're not and if they were i
wouldn't even care just they want
attention
and they say straight up lies others
will say things that are true but that
they really shouldn't be talking about
uh sometimes narcissists will in order
to
get attention they will reveal a secret
that a third party told them that they
really shouldn't be revealing as an
example and that is that that is part of
what donald trump does and he does his
fair share of lying as well
imagine the things he's told people
that we don't know he's told people and
imagine what our adversaries are quietly
doing with that knowledge this man is a
danger
he is a danger and he may get four more
years if we don't do the right thing
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman glad you're with us
today
remember next week we're on vacation the
show is okay we're not canceled
we're just going going on vacation next
week but we've still got a full show
today
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you up to 30 off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com watch
if you're looking for an awesome way to
update your look
the perfect way to do it is with an
elegant high quality
wrist watch when there's a company like
vincero
there is no reason to go spending
thousands of dollars on a watch vincero
is an american company
that's made it possible to own an
excellent watch
without breaking the bank all of their
watches are
masterfully built with high-end
materials
but they're all in the range of about
150 to 250 bucks
i just got a watch from their icon
automatic collection
the one i got is in gunmetal and slate
blue
i love the look it's sleek classy it's
clear that a lot of careful
craftsmanship went into the design
it is definitely my new favorite watch
you'll get up to 30 percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com slash
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video